çok acıktım sizi Google'da Aradığımız
zaman Türk müzik yani Türk besteci
Türkiye'nin iş çıkıyor bunda 140 Hayır
çok mutlu tane özellikle böyle tarifi
[Alkış]
değil ama demek ki öyle a yurt dışında
da böyle bir sunum duydum Peki Sovyetler
Birliğinde Aslında Türkiye'ye geliş ve
burada kalış hikayesi çok kısa
dinleyebilir miyiz Tamam kısa tutmaya
çalışacağım ve şöyle ben Sovyetler
Birliğinde UNESCO üyesiydi mewo öğün
eski için Uluslararası bir film
projesinde yer aldım eski eşim de
senaryo yazarıydı film ekolojik
problemleri
bu ve 30 sene önce takdir edersiniz ki
çok konuşulmayan bir konuydu çıktık bu
üzerine gidiyorduk Uluslararası bir film
7 bir müddet Hindistan'da kaldık ayvarca
Türkiye Yolumuz düştüğü zaman altını
çizeyim Sovyetler Birliği henüz
dağılmadı ve ben hamileydim oğlum doğmak
üzere Doktorlar uçağa binme mi izin
vermedi Böylece benim ilk oğlum Yürek
Türkiye'de doğdu ve o süreçte Aslında
ilk bakıştan ben Türkiye'ye aşık oldum
bakın Kara s satılıyor şöyle bütün bu
iki buçuk yaşındayken mutlak kulak Kula
sahip ne demek mutlak kulak tam olarak
referans noktası olmadan sesleri
duyabilmek hangi not oldu
Ya aslında iki buçuk yaşında iken
notaları biliyordum mutlak kulağıma için
insanın notaları bilmesi gerekiyor Yani
burada belki bir sürü insan var mutlak
kulağa sahip Ama Müzik notalarını
bilmediği için o eşleşme yapılamıyor ama
öğrendikten sonra Evet aslında kulakla
ilgili bir şey değil beynimizde bir
bölge Bununla ilgili Aslında hafıza ile
ilgili bir şey bir ses duyduğumuz zaman
sadece müzik sesi değil yani mekanik
sesler olabilir her türlü ses rüzgar
sesi su akan su sesi her şeyi aslında
müzik boşuna denmiyor müzikler yazı
Sovyetler Birliği Komünist bir rejim
kasa Türkiye'ye geliyorsun Orada
büyüksünüz sanata bakış açısından bu iki
ülkeyi nasıl kıyaslar sınız yani orada
nasıl dışı Türkiye'de nasıl Aslında
bakış
En azından Belki de fark yok ama sanatın
yaşayabilmeyi açısından onu yani ayakta
tutmak için da çok büyük bir fark var
ister istemez Çünkü bizim uyudum
sistemde Her şey bedava eder yani
düşünün bir tane Style bu piyano uçtan
ve galiba fiyatını biliyor musunuz 100
bin euroyu geçiyor Bir tanecik Bizim
okulumuzda okul henüz Kon saat vardı
konsertlar öncesi okulda 120 tane sen ve
piyano vardı Her sınıfta bir öğrenciye
bir hocaya ve biz burnumuzu kırdık Bu
biraz eski bunun sesi iyi değil işte
anahtar dağıtırken Erkan danayı
çalışacağız erkenden gidip iyi
piyanoların olduğu sınıfları seçiyordu
kayıp Bu bir çok şey anlatıyor yani
başka bir şey da anlatmaya gerek yok
çünkü bu
Bu çok iyi bir gösterdiğim çok zor yani
kapitalist sistemin de müzisyenin
yetişmesi ve hayatta durabilmesi
gerçekten zor Çünkü biz de rekabet diye
bir şey de yoktu Yani herkes haydi hep
birlikte aynı hastaneye iyi müzisyen
olalım iyi müzik yapalım insanlarla için
müzik vasıtasıyla olalım diye bir gayesi
vardı ama bir tane sisteminde böyle bir
şey yok hasta küçük bana öyle anlattılar
ben şaşkınlıkla bazı şeyleri fark
ettiğin zaman özellik a Burası öyle
pasta çok küçük müzisyenler çok ne
yapacaksın o zaman böyle canla başla
aslında hiçbir zaman da yarışa girmedim
öreceğim zaten diyorsunuz ki önce
müzikle insanları değiştirme hayatı
dönüştürmeye çalıştım ama şu anda ondan
Vazgeçtim tamamen kendim için kendimi
dönüştürmek daha iyi ifade edebilmek
için müzik yapıyor şöyle
Ya ben müziğin içinde ne doğdum Aslında
babam orkestra şefi ve Felsefe profesörü
uydu Annem koro şefi ve Piyanist Kendimi
Bildim Bileli müziği geçirdim Hatta o
kadar doğal ki ben hani 3 başka meslek
düşündüm dönmedi yaşlarındaki zaten
müzik var ya bir daha meslek yapayım Ama
sonra 17 yaşındayken anladım ki ben
müzik için varım ben müzik için bu
dünyaya geldim benim yaşama şeklim müzik
fakat Türkiye'ye geldikten sonra Aslında
çocukluğumdan beri manevi yaşam benim
için çok önemliydi fakat Türkiye'de bir
de tasavvufla tanıştıktan sonra şöyle
söyleyeyim Aslında altüst noktası buydu
benim için daha anladım ki Evet ben
insan olmak için bu dünyaya geldim Biz
hepimiz insansız olarak geliyoruz ama
hakiki anlamı
bir insan olmak için çok çalışmamız
lazım müzik şahane bir şey şükürler
olsun ki hayatımda var ama o benim için
sadece olağanüstü bir yol arkadaşıdır
müzik Bundan sonra böyle sonra
Türkiye'ye geldikten sonra Hacettepe
Üniversitesi'nde dönem eğitim sistemi
açısından iki ülke değerlendirebilir
misiniz Orada Gerçi bahsetti mi sana her
sınıfta piyonu vardı burada o kadar
olarak ben daha çok klasik müziğe bakış
açısı olarak merak ediyorum Aslında
açısından Türkiye çok iyi bir yerde Türk
müzisyenler Bence haksızlık ediyor Çünkü
Türkiye için klasik müziğin geçmişi çok
çok uzun tarihi bir yoldan geçmedi yani
oldukça yeni kısa dönem içinde olamamış
var ve Hacettepe Üniversitesi'nde yüksek
lisans ve doktora
bu Kay kurabiye hocalarla çalıştım
herkese çok çok teşekkür ediyorum
gerçekten çok iyi bir Ekol var zaten her
bir patik müzikte her ülkenin ekolü o
ülke ile sadece yorulmuyor bir sürü
etkisi var Rusya kolu istedi Ne bileyim
Fransa İngiltere ve saygı ama hepsi
sonradan günlük oluyor bu Türkiye'de çok
güzel bir resim müzik modern klasik
müzik ve kolu de var yani gerçekten
harika besteciler ve eserler var dünya
onları çok hastalığın için ben de
yurtdışına gittiğim zaman muhakkak Türk
bestecilerinin eserlerini çalıyorum Evet
bu ayvazovski İstanbul'u biraz
bahsedebilir misiniz Ben o işinizi çok
diğerlerinden nedense ayrı bir yere
koyuyorum şu an duydum bir proje Aslında
bestecisi ve müzik direktörü olarak
davet edildim boyut yayın grubu tarafın
bu Fakat daha sonra projenin yöneticisi
oldum Çünkü yani insanları seviyorum
benim İnsanlarla güzel dirilişi mi var
diye düşünüyorum ve hani çok zor
fotoğraf olacak şeyler Ben inanıyorum ki
çok böyle kalpten kalp kaldı Gerçekten
çözülüyor İnşallah şimdiki krizde öyle
çok güzel kalpten kalbe çözülsün değil
mi Ne dersiniz Türkiye aşığı bir ressam
Yüzyıl önceki Türkiye Fakat bu tablolar
çok da bilinmiyordu biz yola çıkarken
dünyayı sıra türünde Ayvaz hosting
İstanbul tabloları 32 taneydi bu
Araştırmadan sonra Rusya işleri eski
Sovyetler Birliği Avrupa Amerika özel
koleksiyonlar sarayla şu anda 64 e
çıkarıldı Unique
bu ve gerçekten olağanüstü bir güzellik
ikiyüz sene önceki İstanbul'un sayısında
görebiliyoruz çok büyük bir Mimi anime
edilmiş tablolar üzerine bir saatlik bir
ayvazovski Rapsodi destekledim Senkron
olarak o görüntülerle onları
seslendiriyor disiplinleri bir araya
gelmesi de benim çok iyi fakat şöyle bir
sıkıntı var bence bu işinizden daha çok
klasik müziği popüler kültürle
oryantalya bir araya getirdiğiniz içiniz
konuşuldu Türkiye'de bu orkideli galiba
evet aynen aynen öyle ya Bu nasıl
bakıyorsunuz yani o dönem Hatta alıyor
Antalya video klip de birlikte rol
aldınız o eleştirildi klasik ürünler
Yani bir çeşit muhafazakârlık mı bu
sizce Aslında şöyle klasik müzik
muhafazakar
o zorunda ve Ben de öyleydim Ben belli
bir noktaya kadar cisimli ki o kadar
sıkı bir resim müzik eğitimi aldım
mümkün değil Onun dışında başka bir şey
böyle de korunuyor korumak zorunda ama
aynı zamanda da bir çıkacak bir
çılgınlık yapacak yine alt üst edecek
bir şey be o da yenilik olacak Çaykovski
ya Ne kadar daha klasik olabilirsiniz
içeri KOSGEB ip seslendirildiği zaman
birçok Eser yani salonda yumurta domates
plana atıldı çekos ki bu yani o da Çünki
zamanının muhafazakar sisteminin dışına
çıkan biri ve hep böyle ve sonra onlarda
yani klasik müziğin içinde çerçevesinde
girmiş olur Hadi bir sonraki çılgına
kadar öyle bir şey bakalım dantel oturup
düşündüğüm bir şey değildi bir tekne
deli moralim bozuktu arkadaşlarımın çok
güzeldir müzik koleksiyonu vardı Birini
şaşıracağınız bir şey
bu olmak istediler Ali Rahman muscofen
koyarsak bu büsbütün duygulanır ve
Asena'nın o sırada yeni çıkmış olan
ritim albümünü koydular Allah'ı Ben daha
önce böyle bir şey duymadım Hani
Türkiye'de birkaç deneyim ama da bu
kasasını algıda seçicilik olarak deyip
duymadım algılamadı Bir Ben Bir Allah
Allah Ne oluyor 3. parçaya geçince o
aritmi koyduğumda bakın o anda İçimden
gelen bir domino periyodunu o ritmin
üzerine Çaldık ve akşam projeye aklımda
doğduk Hatta arkadaşlarım dedi ki
Aşağıdayım mısın bu çünkü çok büyük bir
şeydir yani karşı çıkmaya Evet dedim Ben
eminim Bak buraya gelmiş olsaydı ben de
besteciyi moda besteci ben etkilendim
seo'da etkilenir ve o da mutlaka bir şey
yapar işte bak doğuya gelmiş olsaydı
kendi
bu yana doğru bak anlamına geliyor
darbukalar Erkan olağanüstü Avrupalı
Hollandalı Soprano ucu leprince böyle
bir atölye çalışması oldu ve kapakta
şunu yazdım bu çok mühim benim için bu
bir müzik deneyi değil Çağan ihtiyacıdır
insanlar birbirleriyle kucaklaşma dan
önce müzikleri kucaklaştığını istiyorum
böyle bir şey sanıyorum Neyi ne kadar
değerli olduğunu sadece zaman karar
veriyor O zaman çok fazla uzatmayalım
Siz dükkanın başına ki ilk geldiğim
zaman bir beste yapmıştım çok sade bir
beste ismi de aşk bugüne uygun
olabileceğini düşündüm Aslında onu
bestelerken yola çık
bu hem söz vardı ya Hint ve dağlarında
Abi şöyle diyor Aşk tam geldik aşkta
bulunuyoruz aşka geri döneceğiz bunun
üzerine
abone ol
[Müzik]
İyi tamam
abone ol
[Müzik]
bu Türk müziğinden yaptığım bir uyarlama
Haydar Haydar veya Ben melamet hırkasını
çok severim onu sizlerle paylaşmak
istedim bugün Sağ ol
abone ol
Ama şöyle bir şey söylemek istiyorum
tabii ki Çanakkale türküsü bir
kahramanlık destanıdır ama onu uyarlama
biçiminde hem tabi kahramanlık duyguları
da var ama aynı zamanda bu bir ninni ve
bir dua
Evet Ee özellikle ki hayatlarını
kaybetmiş olan o Gencecik insanların
ruhunu bitsin
abone ol
var mı
[Müzik]
o o
[Alkış]
abone ol